greatest of all time a writer and Oscar
winner and the Black Mamba
[Applause]
but to me he was Coco my booboo my baby
my papi chulo
I was his VB his principessa his Reina
his Queen mama mama and his whiskey
menisci fabulous key I couldn't see him
as a celebrity nor just an incredible
basketball player he was my sweet
husband and the beautiful father of our
children he was mine he was my
everything
Kobe and I have been together since I
was 17 and a half years old I was his
first girlfriend his first love his wife
his best friend his confidante and his
protector he was the most amazing
husband
Kobe loved me more than I could ever
Express or put into words
he was the earlybird and I was an idol I
was fire and he was ice and vice versa
at times we balanced each other out he
would do anything for me I have no idea
how I deserved a man that loved and
wanted me more than Kobe he was
charismatic a gentleman he was loving
adoring and romantic
he was truly the romantic one in our
relationship and looked forward to
Valentine's Day and our anniversaries
every year he planned special
anniversary trips and a special
traditional gift for every year of our
marriage he even had made my most
treasured gifts he just thought outside
the box and was so thoughtful even while
working hard to be the best athlete he
give to me the actual notebook and the
blue dress rachel mcadams wore in the
notebook movie when I asked him why he
chose the blue dress he said it was
because it's a scene when Ali comes back
to Noah
we had hope to grow old together like
the movie we really had an amazing love
story we loved each other with our whole
beings two perfectly imperfect people
making a beautiful family and raising
our sweet and amazing girls a couple
weeks before they passed Coby sent me a
sweet text I mentioned how he wanted to
spend time together just the two of us
without our kids because I'm his best
friend first we never got the chance to
do it we were busy taking care of our
girls and just doing our regular
everyday responsibilities but I'm
thankful I have that recent text it
means so much to me Coby wanted us to
renew our vows he wanted Natalia to take
over his company and he wanted to travel
the world together we had always talked
about how would be the fun grandparents
to our daughters children he would have
been the coolest grandpa Coby was the
MVP of girl dad's or MVD he never left
the toilet seat up he always told the
girls how beautiful and smart they are
he taught them how to be brave and how
to keep pushing forward when things get
tough and when Kobe retired from the NBA
he took over dropping off and picking up
our girls from school since I was at
home pregnant with Bianca and just
recently home nursing Capri when Coby
was still playing I used to show up an
hour early to be the first in line to
pick up an authority on Gianna from
school and I told him he couldn't drop
the ball once he took over he was late
one time and we most definitely let him
know that I was never late so he showed
up one hour and 20 minutes early after
that he always knew there was room for
improvement and wanted to do better he
happily did
our pool and enjoyed spending time in
the car with our girls he was a doting
father a father that was hands-on and
present
he helped me bathe biank and Capri
almost every night he would sing them
silly songs in the shower and continue
making them laugh and smile as he
lathered them lotion and got them ready
for bed
he had magic arms and could put Capri to
sleep in only a few minutes he said he
had it down to a science
eight times up and down our hallway he
loved taking Bianca to fashion I are
gonna watch her play in the koi pond
area and love taking her to the park
their most recent visit to the koi pond
was the evening before he and Gigi
passed he shared a love of movies and
the breakdown of films with Natalia he
enjoyed renting out theatres and taking
Athaliah to watch the newest Star Wars
movie or Harry Potter films and they
would have movie marathons and he
enjoyed every second of it he loved her
typical tearjerkers - he liked watching
stepmom steel magnolias and Little Women
he had a tender heart coby's somehow
knew where I was at all times
specifically when I was late to his
games he would worry about me if I
wasn't in my seat at the start of the of
each game and would ask security where I
was at the first time out of the first
quarter and my smart ass would tell him
that he wasn't going to drop 81 points
within the first 10 minutes of the game
I think anyone with kids understands
that sometimes we can't make it out the
door on time and eventually he was used
to my tardiness and balled out the fact
that he could play on an intense
professional level and still be
concerned by making sure we made it to
the game safely it was just another
example of how family came first to him
he loved being Gianna's basketball coach
he told me he wished he would have
convinced Natalia to play basketball so
that they could have spent even more
time together but he also wanted her to
pursue her own passion he watched
Nathanial play in a volleyball
tournament on her birthday on January
19th and he noticed how she's a very
intelligent player he was convinced she
would have made a great point card with
her vision of the court and he told me
that he wanted Bianca and Capri to take
a basketball when they get older so he
could spend just as much time with them
as he did with Gigi and Kobe always told
Bianca and Capri that they were going to
grow up and play basketball and mix they
ass up now they won't have their daddy
and sister here to teach them and that
is truly a loss I do not understand but
I'm so thankful code we heard Coco say
dad he isn't going to be here to drop
Bianca Capri off at pre-k or
kindergarten he wasn't going to be here
to tell me to get a grip V when we have
to leave the kindergarten classroom or
show up to our daughter's doctor's
visits for my own moral support he isn't
going to be able to walk our girls down
the aisle or spin me around on the dance
floor while singing PYT to me but I want
my daughters to know and remember the
amazing person husband and father he was
the kind of man that wanted to teach the
future generations to be better and keep
them from making his own mistakes he
always liked working and doing projects
to improve kids lives he taught us all
valuable lessons about life and sports
through his MBA career
his books his show detail and his puny
x' podcast series and we're so thankful
he let those lessons and stories behind
for us he was thoughtful and wrote the
best love letters and cards and Gigi had
his wonderful ability to express her
feelings into paper and make you feel
her love through her words she was
thoughtful like him
they were so easy to love everyone
naturally gravitated towards them they
were funny happy silly and they loved
life they were so full of joy and
adventure God knew they couldn't be on
this earth without each other he had to
bring them home to heaven together babe
you take care of our chichi and I got
nanny baby and Coco we're still the best
team we love and miss you boo-boo and
Gigi may both rest in peace and have fun
in heaven until we meet again one day we
love you both and miss you forever and
always mommy
[Applause]
you